when you're not a parent you can get
sucked into all sorts of different stuff
and you maybe sometimes forget who you
are you're suddenly as a parent
especially now archie the age he's at
asking all the questions where does he
ask he just those questions of the wife
yeah he's into the y stage yeah why this
why that why that and instead of just
trying to like i don't know move it on i
give him the most honest answer that i
can
and then it goes on and on and on until
he's satisfied and then that's it it's
done yeah otherwise it ends up with
because the world is round and that's
the way that life is that's just the way
it goes
so you know it's like i love it i love
every every part of it i've always
wanted to be a dad i've always wanted to
have my own kids now i've got
two little people who i'm responsible
for do you tell them or do you tell
archie he's old enough about your mom
yes yeah yeah very much so i don't tell
him all the stuff that happened but
suddenly that this is you know grandma
diana and we got a couple of photos up
in the house in these moments do you
ever feel your mom's presence yeah no um
for me um
it's constant it has been over the last
two years more so than ever before
it's almost as though she's done her
done her bit with my with my brother and
now she's very much like helping me got
him set up now she's helping me set up
that's what it feels like you know
um he's got he's got his kids i've got
my kids
you know the circumstances are obviously
different but no she i
i feel her presence in almost everything
that i do now
but definitely more so in the last two
years than ever before your family uh at
home do you miss them
um yes i think especially over the last
two years for most people have they not
missed their family right the inability
to be able to get home yeah and see them
of course that's a yeah that's a huge
part of it
but do you miss
your brother your dad
look i mean i'm
for me at the moment i'm here yeah focus
on these guys and these families and
giving everything i can 120 to them to
make sure that they have the experience
of a lifetime yeah that's my focus here
and then when i leave here i get back
and my focus is my family who i miss
massively you do like that of course i
do they're too too little people you
know
like this whole working from home stuff
is
is is not all it's cracked up to be um
certainly post covered because it's
really hard but when your kids and you
are in the same place it's really hard
to separate the work from
from them because they kind of overlap
so i mean lg spends more time
interrupting our zoom calls
um than anybody else um so you have your
personality also gets us off them as
well so that's also a nice thing your
grandmother's going to be 96 you know
what's the best thing about her she's
her sense of humor yeah and her ability
to see the the humor in so many so many
different things
we have a really special relationship we
talk about things that she can't talk
about with anybody else
um so that's always a nice piece to it
but i think she's i think after certain
age you get bored of birthdays you do
you think she's bored of her 96. she
won't be bored of the jubilee will she
uh no okay i don't think so
she's had a few jubilees now so evan
everyone said every everyone is slightly
different yeah i'm sure she's looking do
you think you'll come i don't know yet
there's lots of things with security uh
issues and everything else so this is
what i'm trying to do trying to make it
possible that you know i can
get my kids to meet her